what's up what's up chris good evening
hear me okay yeah you're loud and clear
all right sometimes this mic is
finicky yeah well first i'll do my own
um
endorsement so i mean i think rich the
first video i saw from yours was
actually while i was still in the living
ltr
probably back in the fall and it was i
think at that point your most popular
video which was
uh three women not to date there was one
about daddy issues and i think
i don't know if i'd been searching for
daddy issues and i saw that and i was
like holy [ __ ]
um and even one of the btts paulie you
were on i think the one my covert
narcissism that one i've listened to
probably like four times in a row just
like checking off the boxes so
um but guys if you guys listening out
there i mean i'm in the one percent
community
you know if you can do it do it you know
it's not for thin skin guys like we're
i'm in it and people will tell you
what's up like we're all there to make
each other better
i mean rich i think even since my
conversation when i was here a couple
months ago with you and aaron clary
um you know i have moved into a new
place i got a new job that now i'm
making six-figure income
feeling much better the [ __ ] link when
it is gone i'm spinning multiple plates
at this point so
i'm having more fun now and more success
in my career with women than i've ever
had and you're certainly a big part of
that so
um yeah so i chatted with you guys a
little bit on stereo i guess it was
yesterday
and i thought this might be good
especially um
paul from like the pragmatic standpoint
about actionable items and actually how
to have this conversation so just as a
as a refresher spinning a couple plates
right now and i'm getting to that two to
three month period where
it's either starting to happen or i
understand it's getting ready to happen
where
the conversation is around the what are
we you know where is this going are you
with other women you know what do i can
i am
are we locking this down and so my ideal
scenario is that i would have
a handful or a mini harem of women that
i'm
sleeping with spending time with and
keeping your rotation but they're going
to be sexually exclusive to me and i
don't want to share them with other men
so
um you know i know that the first step
is like let's draw that boundary and
just say hey
if you don't like it there's the door
but as far as maybe navigating those
waters a little bit and having that
conversation in real time
just i think some of the guys out there
that may be um
interested in facing a similar situation
could could benefit
on hearing your advice how many of them
are asking you
for exclusivity by the way like all
three right now it's not
right now it's none but i'm getting i'm
hearing from them more often it's not
just one of these things usually it's
like hey
let's hang out next wednesday cool i'll
see you then and now like more
frequently the textures are incoming and
i'm keeping them at arm's length still a
couple texts here and there hey i gotta
run i got meetings
etc etc still not doing a ton of chit
chat but i can kind of see that
um with the amount of contacting me and
how often and how
in the things that it's about and how
often they want to see me that we're
starting to
go down that path a little bit i'll i'll
um you know hand this over to paul in a
minute but i'll
say this like i think that um you
shouldn't even be entertaining a
conversation about where do we stand
unless it's been at least three to six
months and it's gonna be like you know
three to six months of good behavior and
even then
if you're not interested uh you know in
a monogamous ltr then just
tell them like hey you know i don't
think monogamy's good for me doesn't
work
um i dig your vibe i'm completely good
with you know continue to roll this way
but just understand that um
i'm gonna be seeing other women from
time to time i'm not gonna put your
health at risk meaning i'm not going to
be like raw dog
you know sort of thing um i'm not going
to embarrass you
but uh that's how i roll so if you're
cool with that then we can keep doing
that and then if she's good with that
then the next thing you're going to drop
is and i expect you to be sexually
monogamous with me and if those things
don't work there's a door over there and
you can walk out of it
paul chris is thinking dude i can't
imagine having this conversation
i can tell look at his face that's all
right though listen
um well first of all to kind of think
about how you'd want to design
your life around uh having different
women so
at the rule zero conference i did a um
presentation on harems right and how to
actually run a harem where
not only your girl is consensual uh to
using other women but she invites it
wants it
and wants to be a part of it so i mean
depending on what you want
that's an option these really you have
to decide though
how you want to design your life with
women
we didn't get into this much in stereo
but it's good to get into here if you
want monogamy and that's your values
that's what you want
cool if you would be open to that or you
want to just keep spinning plates
forever or for a long time that's fine
whatever it is you want you decide what
that is first i think the biggest
problem is you know i thought about your
question
stuff after we talked yesterday i think
the biggest thing that i forget to tell
guys
is you have to set your frame to begin
with which means knowing what you want
it to look like knowing what you want
your goals to look like if you don't
know
what it looks like or should look like
and if that's possible or how
then how do you present that right to
the other person it ends up becoming
that a negotiation
and because you don't want to lose these
chicks right you don't want to lose
sexual access
and that's not what you want it to turn
into so if you have a vision you know
what it looks like that's
that's the first thing now why don't we
answer that question first and i'll
point in the right direction at a
practical level so
what are you just going to do you ever
do you want a relationship eventually do
you want to keep it plates forever
do you want to do plates now for a long
time and then maybe later or like
what do you what would it look like for
you yeah paul so rich knows a little bit
more background on my situation so i'm
four or five months removed from a two
and a half year long ltr live in the dog
that whole thing
the dream of the white picket fence um
so i'm 29
and so you know i'm thinking at least a
couple of years before even really
entertaining the idea
of you know i'm i'm getting into now i'm
really starting to hit my stride when it
comes to my career i'm doing some
traveling
uh you know i've made complete lifestyle
changes where i was a couple of months
ago so
um that's a really good question that i
hadn't thought about a lot i mean
i think maybe i say tongue-in-cheek it's
like well i'd rather just have
you know three girlfriends and then
they'll be cool with it but
understanding
how much time and resources that if i'm
gonna treat them all the same and
equally like that's
it's not just you know a cakewalk right
so um i don't know if that means
letting the cream rise to the top and
then bringing other women in
periodically or if that's
i have you know the multiple committed
sort of multiple committed women to me
and vice versa so
so yeah i mean that's something i
definitely would have to think about um
and and probably make a decision on
rather quickly
yeah you just just think about what you
want it to look like not that it has to
be that way today but what you'd be open
for
you're never going for the commitment
right you're protecting the commitment
you know so she should be going for that
from you you're protecting yourself from
getting into a commitment
that could ruin your life essentially or
be a huge hindrance
and so these women have to prove to you
that they're
better for you as a compliment than
as someone you keep at arm's length or
as someone you don't have in your life
at all
that's the burden of proof is on them to
do that so that's where your framework
should be of course but then having that
that vision so what i what i find is
that
for productivity and accomplishing stuff
either monogamy or what i sort of do
which would be or what a lot of guys do
which is having
that ltr that on the surface looks
exactly like a normal
long-term relationship that you would
have with you know that you could go to
your you know family functions and go to
uh a
a party at work or something and and
everything's normal right
but you occasionally bring in other
girls you don't you don't have to worry
about treating
other girls in your life equally now all
right these girls come in and it serves
their purpose to have
sexual experiences and a good time with
you and your chick
or even sometimes just with you she
realizes that you know
this is an enhancement of your
relationship rather than a hindrance
and then you're not trying to manage
like multiple lives because the more
girls you add in as more permanent
fixtures
the more management you have to do now
on those relationships and that takes
away
from you achieving stuff that's reason
why i don't
look at it like oh bring in you know i'm
going to bring in another ltr and
another lcr why don't i do that
it's because i think that would be a lot
more to manage and now my time and
energy goes into that and that's not
it's not good for me right and so
you basically want them if they're
spending more time with you and you've
invited them
more like you know i say draw these you
know perimeters around you and invite
people that you
know like can trust and have proven
themselves closer and closer to the
inside of your
you know perimeters you want to make
sure that they're not a drain on your
time and resources right like if you're
going to run it this way
you want to make sure that this is not
what you're spending all your time on
managing drama between
because there's a lot of guys that will
[ __ ] run like multiple checks and
their life's a nightmare
like they spend all their time you know
dealing with them fighting with each
other and the [ __ ] cattiness and all
this sort of stuff
and if you're getting yourself to a
position like that the juice ain't worth
the squeeze
right like i've been making sure that
you like like paul says like you have
early frame
announcement and then you manage that
throughout the length of the whole thing
and anytime they get out of line it's
like [ __ ] soft necks and if they
continue to do it then just get rid of
that you have to be fastidious about
your time and your purpose you know here
and
focus on that and don't let these
[ __ ] chicks get in the way of that
right
yeah and so like so now practical going
forward you figure out what it looks
like and then it's easy to present the
frame now
because you know what it looks like
you're very clear in your purpose
now a chick says hey you know what are
we where we stand and it's been three
months you just say hey you know what
done the long-term relationship and it
got bad real fast
i don't want to be trapped in that so
let's just let things grow organically
and see how things go
and it's going to be that way for a
while and i hope that you're cool with
that because if you're not
i don't know what to tell you i enjoy my
time with you
let's just keep enjoying our time and
that's your discussion
right now if it's a year down the line
they're like where do we stand or or
let's say
differently right let's say there's
something that kind of disqualifies
there's an ltr like let's say
she's showing her butthole on instagram
every day yeah for likes okay
and but she's cool other than that right
so then you just kind of look in and go
you know what i really like spending
time with you i like our time together
but honestly you do a lot of things that
are not really relationship behaviors
i'm surprised you'd even ask me that
question yeah oh what do you mean well i
mean
look at your instagram not judging for
it but i can't be in a relationship with
someone who signals the other men like
that
so we'll just hang out and have fun and
whatever we'll see how it goes then
that's your frame
watch her behavior change now and her be
more of a qualified
prospect for an ltr or it doesn't change
and you know where to put her
does that make sense totally yeah i
think i think it's a little early right
but as well i mean this all yeah it's
early but
yeah it's a good you know timeline and
things to be thinking about but yeah
i'll let you guys move on i appreciate
it guys all right brother thanks
you